[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
yes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
hey
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
more
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
my
is
[Music]
[Music]
r
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
you
with faith in jesus christ we receive
the body of our sister
madeleine corbell albright for burial
let us pray with confidence to god the
giver of life
that he will raise her to perfection
in the company of the saints
deliver your servant madeline sovereign
lord christ
from all evil and set her free from
every bond
that she may rest with all your saints
in the eternal habitations
where with the father and the holy
spirit you live and reign one god
forever and ever amen
let us also pray for all who mourn
that they may cast their care on god
and know the consolation of his love
almighty god look with pity upon the
sorrows of your servants for whom we
pray
remember them lord in mercy
nourish them in patience
comfort them with a sense of your
goodness
lift up your countenance upon them and
give them peace
through jesus christ our lord amen
this is my song
[Music]
peace
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
i am resurrection and i am life says the
lord whoever has faith in me shall have
life
even though she die
and everyone who has life and has
committed herself to me in faith
shall not die forever
as for me i know that my redeemer lives
and at the last he shall stand upon the
earth
after my awaking he will raise me up
and in my body i shall see god
i myself shall see
and my eyes behold him
who is my friend and not a stranger
for none of us has life in herself
and none becomes her own master when she
dies
for if we have life we are alive in the
lord
and if we die
we die in the lord
so then
whether we live or die
we are the lord's possession
happy from now on
are those who die in the lord
for they rest
from their labors
good morning
my name is randy hollereth and i'm the
dean of washington national cathedral
and on behalf of marianne buddy the
episcopal bishop of the diocese of
washington
and the entire cathedral community
welcome
welcome to this house of prayer for all
people
it is an honor to host this service
for madeleine albright
to ann and alice and katie and the
entire albright family
our hearts are with you and with all
those across our country
and around the world who grieve the loss
of this great american
secretary albright was a wonderful
friend to this cathedral
twice over she served as a member of the
chapter
the cathedral's governing board
she was a parent and a grandparent of
students in the schools here on the
close
and she was loved and admired by all who
knew her
we say goodbye today to a remarkable
human being
madeleine was a leader mentor
trailblazer
reconciler and patriot
she was a person of deep faith
who always held firm to the highest
ideals of her faith
and her country
she has died but she has not been lost
madeleine lives now in god
and she leaves all of us a legacy that
will serve as a blessing
for many many years to come
having fought the good fight and kept
the faith
grant her we beseech thee dear god
the crown of life that fadeth not away
amen
hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
freedom endures
against all odds
in the face of every aggressor
because they're always those
who will fight for that freedom
in the 20th and 21st century
freedom had no greater champion
than madeleine corbell albright
ann
alice katie
your mom was a force
a force of nature
with her goodness and grace
her humanity
and her intellect
she turns the tide of history
david
daniel jack
jake ben and ellie
you're too young to remember this
but when the iron curtain fell
the berlin wall came down
our world faced one of those inflection
points
once in a generation moment of upheaval
but opportunity as well
people in nations around the world
were deciding the future they wanted to
make for themselves
and your grandmother
your grandmother
as a madam ambassador and as the first
female secretary of state
in american history
made sure those
nations
and those people
knew exactly
where the united states of america stood
and what we stood for
you know
and all through it
her beloved sister kathy and her brother
john can attest
she never forgot where she came from or
who she was
president obama
president secretary clinton
vice president al gore
members of congress
cabinet members past and present
today we honor
a truly proud american
who made
all of us prouder to be americans
i also want to welcome
the distinguished guests and dignitaries
who've traveled from around the world to
celebrate
a daughter of the czech republic
who knew
who knew what it meant to endure war
and flee persecution
with her friend
baklava havel
when he died
i remember
when madeline eulogized him
she used these words and i quote
he cast light into places of deepest
darkness
and reminded us constantly
of our obligations to one another
these words
these words
apply equally to madeleine
when i got word that madeline passed i
was in midair
on my way to europe to meet with our
nato allies in brussels to
help try to continue to keep the
the strong strong alliances together
our organization and the international
response to russia's brutal
and unjustifiable
war against ukraine
it was not lost on me
that madeleine was a big part of the
reason
nato was still strong
and galvanized
as it is today
and a few days later
i traveled to poland
and spoke
about all that was at stake
in our world
and for democracy and freedom
which is under assault
from forces of autocracy
and oppression
many are tired of hearing me say i think
we're at another inflection point in
world history
where there is literally
a severe contra
confrontation
between autocrats and democratic nations
president clinton
bill was not lost on me
that you spoke at the same warsaw castle
that i was about to speak at 25 years
earlier
in my case it was evening
the interior of the castle a beautiful
courtyard
holds about five six hundred people
and mostly poles and ukrainians were
present when i spoke
and i'm sure
men in the audience spoke english
though likely not their first language
but when i mentioned the name they were
respectful what i was saying
but when i mentioned
the name of madeleine albright
it was a deafening cheer
they all stopped
everything
they started to cheer
it was spontaneous
it was real
for her name
is still synonymous
with america
as a force for good in the world
madeleine never minced words or wasted
time
when she saw something needed fixing
or someone
who needed
helping just got to work
as a member of the senate foreign
relations committee from the time i was
a kid
oh god there were the good old days
i uh
i was the chairman or the ranking member
for a good part of that time
and uh in the 90s i can attest
that
madeleine
with the significant help of the
president of the united states
kept the committee really busy
and our work
to halt genocide and the balkans
support new democracies in eastern
and central europe
to develop plain colombia
and all those undertakings
madeleine
was an incomparable ally
an advisor beyond the president to me
and to others of the committee
she always had a knack for explaining
to the american people
why it mattered to them
the people everywhere in the world
were struggling
to breathe free
the mattel didn't stop
when she left government
for decades
she was a nexus for the foreign policy
community
always and i mean always
on top of the latest developments
always speaking out for democracy
and always
the first to sound the alarm
about fascism
presidents and leaders around the world
continue to solicit her advice
including me
when i asked her last year to chair the
defense policy board
she built businesses
she pumped out
new york times best sellers
that were both highly prescient and
deeply salient
and constantly best sellers
i think i've read them all
you know
and she
and she mentored
generations
of rising foreign policy experts
the quote foreign policy establishment
you know
and the thing that i
noted that was deliberate and remarkable
about her
not unlike secretary clinton
was that she made sure that young women
knew they belonged at every single table
having to do with national security
without
exception today
across our government and around the
world
madeleine's proteges are legion
many are here today
each carrying with them
a spark lit by her passion
and her brilliance
i think part of the reason why madeleine
was such a successful diplomat
was that she understood
something i've always believed
and
my boss
president obama when i was vice
president
used to kid me because i repeat so often
because i believed she understood
something i've always believed that all
politics
especially international politics is
personal
and all ultimately
it's personal
she could go toe-to-toe with the
toughest dictators
then turn around
and literally teach a fellow ambassador
how to do the macarena on the floor of
the u.n security council
you all think i'm kidding
i'm not kidding
she thought it was too difficult to
teach me how to dance though
she was right
no matter where she was
she understood people
she cared about people
and all of that was grounded in an
education game by watching her father
george joseph corbin and her mentor as
well
she learned diplomacy at the dinner
table
and throughout her life
nothing mattered to madeleine
more than the family
nothing
madeleine had the same role that i do
and others here do no matter what's
happening in my day
as president obama can tell you
or who i'm meeting with
if one of my children calls
i take the call
she was the same way
ann alice katie
and your grandchildren
each of you
each you is literally a tribute
to her enormous to her enormous capacity
to love
i know it's hard
but i promise you
she's always with you in your mind
in your heart
and part of your soul
and i promise you
you're gonna have a tough decision
you're gonna be asking yourself
what would she want me to do
not a joke
remember i said it
that's gonna happen
and kathy and john
the connection the three of you
maintained through your lives
was always an anchor to madeleine
to all the ups and downs of life
what a gift
what a gift what a family
you know from that
first transatlantic crossing on the ss
america
to landing in nations around the world
and that big blue and white plain
emblazoned with the words united states
of america
madeleine understood her story
was america's story
her story was america's story
she loved to speak about america
as the indispensable nation
to her
the phrase was never a statement of
arrogance
it was about gratitude
for all this country made possible for
her
it was a testament to her belief
in the endless
possibilities
that only america could help unlock
around the world and
her to understanding
what america power
could achieve
one is united
with and motivated by
enduring american values
that's why there was nothing she loved
more
than swearing in new citizens
to this great nation of ours
she'd light up
reminding them
that she once stood where they stood
having gained the blessings of liberty
she wanted nothing more
than to share them
around the globe
to madeleine from my perspective
there was no higher mission
no greater honor than to serve this
great experiment of freedom
known as the united states of america
may her memory continue
to be a blessing to our nation
and may we remember
her words and her deeds
may she always be a light
to all those in the darkest places
reminder
of our obligation to one another
and god bless
madeleine albright
hey
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
here
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
me
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
um
uh
and alice
katie
to all the
spouses the grandchildren
sister kathy and brother john
thank you for giving
hillary and me the chance to say a few
words
mr president
president mrs obama vice president gore
all the members of congress and
the diplomatic corps and cabinet's past
and presence
and especially to all of you
who had the distinct
honor
and i hope the joy
of working with madeleine
albright our last conversation was
two weeks before she passed away
and
we only spent the first few minutes
telling stories that
we swore were true
and joking with each other and
and then
i said
tell me how you're feeling
she said look i got a little problem
here but i've got a perfectly good
doctor i'm doing exactly what he tells
me to do
so i'm getting good care and whatever
happens will be the best outcome i can
get let's don't waste any time on that
the only thing that really matters is
what kind of world we're going to leave
to our grandchildren
i will never forget that conversation as
long as i live it was so
perfectly madeline
yeah i'd like to live to be 90 95 100
but the thing that really matters is
what's going to happen to our
grandchildren's generation are we going
to lose our freedom we're going to lose
our democracy
have we decided after all that all that
matters are our differences
in this fleeting life instead of what we
have in common
and so
madeleine
made a decision
that's with her last breath
she would
go out with her boots on
in this case
supporting president biden and all of
america's efforts
to help ukraine
what kind of world are we going to leave
to our grandchildren
that question's kind of up in the air
but not because of madeleine albright
i was honored to be part of her life for
more than 30 years
i was thrilled
when
chelsea got to meet her and what an
influence she had on chelsea and lots of
other
young women
i was
amazed by the friendship she formed with
hillary and grateful for that
but i met her a long time ago she was
working in the new caucus campaign and
i um
i'm a graduate of georgetown where she
taught so i
knew her by reputation and beca i knew
she'd been voted the
best teacher by the
students twice
but when i finally met her i realized
that
she was even better than advertised
she was smart tough-minded talented
she had a great sense of humor
and a clear grasp
of the post-cold war world we were
moving into
and
so when i was elected i asked madeline
to manage the transition
for the national security council
which wound up filled with incredibly
gifted
balanced people and we had
more problems than we could say grace
over and we needed every one of them
and
as i watched her more
i decided to ask her be
the ambassador to the united nations
because her life story was about to
become the story of the last part of the
20th century and much of the world
and because she could be the voice
of america at its best
and after four years
in which she
continued to defy expectations and
sometimes raise eyebrows
now i have to say this she would never
forgive me if i didn't mention this at
her funeral
when the cubans
shot down the brothers to the rescue
planes
in violation of international law
they had a conversation which madeleine
got a copy of on the
on their radios between the planes
about how
they had shown their cojones by
shooting down
a totally
defenseless
couple of planes
that were dropping pro-democracy
leaflets
in cuba
and parenthetically then almost
certainly outside cuban airspace when
they were shot down but it was illegal
to do it in an airplane
so
madeleine says
that's not cajones that's cowardice
and all of a sudden it was on the lips
of everybody in south florida
and uh
and she was being criticized some people
said so undiplomatic it's unladylike and
south americans all this on this on that
and i called her and i said
i'm just jealous
it's the best line developed delivered
by anybody in this administration since
i've been here
and keep on going and
it was great
we spent a happy day together
two years ago in kosovo 20 years after
the conflict there
freed them of a genuine threat of
genocide
we walked hand in hand through pristina
on a sunny sunny june day
down the street there were about a
quarter of a million people there with a
lot of people in a small country like
that
and
we came
to the subject of our stroll
which was a beautiful bust of madeleine
in a
shrub surrounded
tall
stand
that was
their tribute to her
for being there for them
we see that legacy honored
all the things she did with
kosovo with bosnia
we see it in so many ways today
we have the president the prime minister
and the former president of kosovo here
we
have the foreign minister of bosnia and
herzegovina
it took us until the slaughter of
srebrenica but finally we got enough
people together to do what's now being
done
in a different way
to try to save ukraine
from the day she entered the u.n until
the day she left
she tried to stick up
for people who were left out and left
behind and
in spite of all of its imperfections and
we all know them
i'm very grateful that the piece is held
in bosnia for now
more than 26 years
we see your legacy honored here by the
presence of the vice president of
colombia
where madeline believed being a good
neighbor was
dealing with a country that was the
oldest democracy in south america where
a third of the land was then under
control of the narco traffickers
with plan colombia
[Music]
just a few years later
the 50th anniversary of the
inter-american
development bank was held in medellin
formerly the drug capital of the world
she believed in that
so you leave it in the integrity of the
all the
former republics of the soviet union
and i believe the president of georgia
is here today and i'm very grateful
for that
i'm grateful that she
was an aggressive voice
supporting vice president gore and we
were trying to sound the alarm on
climate change
and
we didn't always win in case you
didn't notice
for example
when al flew to
japan to get the kyoto accord the first
ever international agreement on climate
change
the senate voted against it 98 to
nothing before he got off the airplane
home
but madeline thought it was the right
thing to do and she kept banging the
drone
and i think time has proved her out
the secretary of state's job
as i came to learn firsthand as a
traveling job
i was fortunate to travel many miles
with her
when i first heard that she passed away
the very first thing i did i was home
in new york was to go into the kitchen
and look at these two beautiful
paintings from haiti
that madeline gave hillary and me
because she knew how much we cared about
what happened there
and
there are just so many things that
i remember
i remember that in addition to colombia
she was always interested in argentina
not only because they were a very strong
ally of the united states
but because when i went on the state
visit there and she went with me
i went into with hillary we went into a
dance hall
in downtown buenos aires and there was
madeleine dancing a mean tango
the rest of us were looking for lessons
matt
she was looking for the dance floor
she was always about a half a step ahead
on a lot of these things that
matter a lot
i'm saying this all because
she was a really
fully developed woman
i mean her life wasn't sort of a
microcosm of the late 20th century in
europe in the united states her
family was run out of their
home first
by hitler and then by stalin
she came to america still not knowing
the true story of her family and what
they had done to survive she was
after she was secretary of state she
finally learned that
she was actually raised jewish and had
three of her four grand
children
and grandparents
die in the holocaust
somehow in the middle of all that
we gave an
distinguished
czech diplomat and his family
a chance to come to america as refugees
and their daughter wound up
becoming
ambassador to the u.n and secretary of
state
and doing lots of other good things
she made us
laugh she made us cry
some of us she made man
but
she had a full hopeful life because she
knew what she believed in she knew what
she was for she knew what she was
against
and she wanted other people
to feel the same way and then to talk
about it instead of kill each other over
it
that's basically her simple political
philosophy
today we see in ukraine all too
tragically what madeleine always knew
that the advance of freedom is neither
inevitable or permanent
and that in politics
where the lure of power is strong
and the temptation to abuse it is often
irresistible
there are no permanent victories
or defeats
her
book on fascism was one of many she
wrote i personally love the one she
wrote
comparing
the relationship of religion and
politics in different countries
she just was
curious i want you to remember that
she was a great secretary of state i she
did 20 other things i could mention
but the most important thing is
god gave her a fine mind
a wealth of experience for anybody who
was willing to pay attention to it
and she made the most of it not just for
herself but for other people she loved
this country more than you will ever
know
and one of my
proudest sad moments
was when we went together to vachav
havel's funeral
and i believe that his
wife dagmar and
high officials of the czech government
are here today too
madeline spoke for the united states
and we were in the national cathedral it
was freezing cold
and madeleine got up
and started mourning
and paying tribute
to her friend
in their native tongue
the impact on the audience
was electric
she spoke about five languages i think
four more than i do anyway
some would say five but anyway she
the impact was electric
and i kept thinking
this is what america is about
that a hard-working immigrant family
could come here
and it could come to this
so i ask you
madeline said once that
we can't just be actors
we have to be authors of our own history
she was a great author
but will people read
remember
follow
this is what you would want me to say
today
i had a good life
i was happy i was so blessed in my
family and my work and friends
but freedom
and democracy and the rule of law
are not
permanently enshrined
just because we've survived 200 plus
years
now
think about the world you want for your
grandchildren
and work for it
we love you madeleine
we miss you
but i pray to god
we never stop hearing you
just sit on our shoulder and nag us to
death so we do the right thing
god bless you
thank you
yes
okay
so
president biden
president and mrs obama
president clinton
vice president gore
secretaries of state
members of the cabinet members of
congress and friends from
literally around the world
gathered on this glorious day in this
magnificent cathedral
to celebrate the extraordinary life and
service
of madeleine
corble
albright
to madeline's beloved family
her brother john
and sister kathy
her daughters ann alice and katie
her sons-in-law her six grandchildren
thank you for sharing her with us all of
these years
madeline and i bonded over many things
but in recent years
we bonded over the joy
of being grandmothers
nothing made her light up
like talking about all of you
or
as bill has said
made her more determined to help build
a better freer
safer world
that mission which animated her entire
life
never wavered
in her last memoir
she shared the urgency that she always
felt
she wrote
there is no shortage of worthwhile work
to be done
and no surplus of seasons
in which to do it
that is the wisdom of a woman who
learned too early in life that
life is fragile
freedom can't be taken for granted
democracy must be defended
peace must be won
and there is no time to waste
doing any of that
it is the resolve of the refugee who
fled tyranny twice before the age of 11.
and it is
the determination
of a diplomat
who knew war
and worked
to end it
i was privileged to know madeleine
through many seasons of our lives
and she was always in a hurry to do good
we first met in the 1980s
at a benefit for the children's defense
fund here in washington
she introduced herself
as a fellow wellesley college graduate
and the seeds of our friendship
were sown
we called each other 59 and 69.
she was 10 years ahead of me in college
but in some ways
it might have been
a different century altogether
the commencement speaker
when she graduated from wellesley
a former secretary of defense
told the class of 1959
that their main responsibility
was to get married and raise interesting
children
now madeline did that of course
but instead of resting on her
maternal laurels
or even resting while her newborn twins
were in the neonatal intensive care unit
she decided
presciently
it was time to learn russian at the
local college
later as a professor herself she
inspired her students
to share her spirit of urgency and
action
silence may be golden she told them
but it won't win many arguments
you have to interrupt
this came in handy
when bill named her ambassador to the
united nations in 1993 and then
secretary of state in 1996.
now it's been said
that i urged my husband
to nominate her
as our first female secretary of state
unlike much that said
this story is true
and i was thrilled
when he agreed
when dictators dragged their feet or
ambassadors filibustered
madeleine never hesitated to speak up
and just in case they didn't get the
message she would put on a snail pin
to signal her impatience
a dozen times a day she would ask her
team
what's next turning her boundless energy
and intellect to yet another crucial
global challenge
she was irrepressible wickedly funny
very stylish
and always ready for a laugh
she brought the same energy to her
friendships
as she did
to her diplomacy
yes it's true
she did teach the foreign minister of
botswana the macarena at a u.n security
council meeting and
snuck off early from an official event
to do the tango in buenos aires
she was even invited to compete
on dancing with the stars
after she tore up the dance floor
at chelsea's wedding
in the arms i would add of a much
younger very handsome man
she guest starred on tv shows like
gilmore girls and madam secretary in
fact
she and colin powell
of blessed memory and madeleine and i
were on
that series which we all three loved and
actually watched
and
madeline was always
making a point to the scriptwriter that
would not have happened
and finally colin said to her madeline
it's fiction it's a story
she said i know but i want them to get
it right
she took me on a memorable walking tour
of her beloved prague in the midst of a
driving rainstorm
which left us both laughing so hard we
hardly noticed
and we spent a memorable evening
together
at the home of president and mrs hobble
just
the four of us having dinner
and i got to listen to them talk about
what it meant
for their beloved country
to be free
she met regularly
with a group of former foreign ministers
who were known
as madeleine and her exes
and yes i just want to make it clear
she really could press
leg press
400 pounds
when that first came out there were
doubters
anyone who knew madeleine didn't but not
everyone had that great pleasure
and so she
made it very clear by going to her gym
as soon as the article came out to do it
again so that people would know
yes
she did
and she mentored the next generation of
women leaders
through vital voices and organization
that she and i helped to start back in
the late 90s
and the albright institute at her
beloved wellesley college
she relished her annual
journey north to wellesley outside of
boston each winter
to meet with the institute's fellows
they came from all corners of the globe
to hear from experts to think critically
about our biggest challenges and to
prepare for central roles in solving
them
and very often she would call me when
she returned
with just such enthusiasm in her voice
about the
young women that she had just spent time
with and what they were going to do
in the future
she led the american delegation to the
historical u.n conference on women in
beijing in 1995
and she urged me to push the envelope on
women's rights in the speech i delivered
there
she also came with us the next day about
45 minutes outside of beijing to where
the non-governmental organizations and
the activists had been sent
and where we in the midst of a driving
rain another driving rain with me and
madeline
waded through the mud
trying to avoid the security from the
chinese government who were not happy
that madeleine and i were there
in order to speak to those women
who would go home across the world to
spread the message that women's rights
are human rights she never blinked
she just
pulled herself up to her full height
which i never believed was five feet but
however high it was she took every inch
and every
part of her spine was as straight as a
steel bar
and just looked at the security people
and said
get out of our way we're going to our
meeting
she didn't just help other women
she spent her entire life counseling and
cajoling
inspiring and lifting up so many of us
who are here today
so the angels
better be wearing their best pins
and putting on their dancing shoes
because if as adeline believed there's a
special place in hell for women who
don't support other women
they haven't seen anyone like her yet
and yes on top of all that
she continued to issue blunt warnings
about the dangers posed by
authoritarianism and fascism with
undeniable moral clarity
until the end she was still in a hurry
to do good
as bill said during the last phone call
two weeks before she died
she talked about the importance of what
president biden
is doing to rally the world
against putin's horrific invasion of
ukraine
and the urgent work of defending
democracy at home and around the world
she knew better than most and she warned
us in her book on fascism
that yes it can
happen here
and time and courage
are of the essence
the bible tells us that to everything
there is a season and a time and purpose
under heaven
a time to weep
and a time
to laugh
if madeleine were here with us today she
would also remind us this must be
a season of action
and yes once again
we must heed
the wisdom of her life and the cause of
her public service
stand up to dictators and demagogues
from the battlefields of ukraine to the
halls of our own capital
defend democracy at home
just as vigorously as we do abroad
live up to the ideals of the country
that welcomed
an 11 year old refugee sailing into new
york harbor on a ship called ss america
and made her secretary of state
let us honor madeleine's life
and legacy
by being the indispensable nation she
loved and served
and let us live as she did
in a hurry to do the most good we can
with every season
under heaven
godspeed 59
god bless you dear madeleine
we will never ever forget you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
president biden
president obama
mrs obama
president clinton secretary clinton
speaker pelosi leader mcconnell
mayor bowser
governor hogan
secretaries blink and carrie rice
leaders and friends from abroad
members of congress and the diplomatic
corps
bishop buddy
all those
who are here and all those watching from
afar
we speak
for our entire family
in thanking you
for joining
in this ceremony
of celebration
and remembrance
most of you knew madeleine albright as a
colleague in government or business
a teacher
or a champion of democracy and human
rights
to the world
these were the many hats she wore
but to our family
she also wore others
that of devoted sister
aunt
grandma maddie
and for the three of us the best mom
ever
of course even great moms have quirks
when we were little
my sisters and i often awoke to the odd
maternal cry
up an atom
said the molecule
usually
usually mom had risen hours earlier to
work on her phd dissertation
fix our breakfasts and organize our
backpacks
when we were at summer camp
she constantly sent us notes about was
whatever was on her mind
the state of the garden
plumbing issues
or
whether we thought it would be okay
for her to take a job on capitol hill
her handwriting was distinctive
and indecipherable
her m's all looked like w's
and so the signature on our library
cards identified our mother as wadalyn
albright
now some people
in the lingo of our czech grandmother
like to
play it by the ears
not mom
she loved schedules and knowing the
order of her day
she had boundless energy and was always
planning for what came next
she described herself
as an optimist who worries a lot and we
can all attest to her worries
she was incredibly protective
but no matter how much she took on
no matter how much of the world was on
her plate
we always knew
that when we needed her
she would take our calls
say here i am
and come quick
of course we worried about her too
especially after she became u.n
ambassador and militants cursed and
threw rocks at her in the balkans
the resulting t-shirt
i got stoned with madeleine albright
made us smile
but the reality did not
and from then on we insisted that she
tell us in advance
where she was going
who she'd be with
or otherwise we declared
you'll be grounded
as we got older
mom never tried to steer us in one
direction or another
she just urged us to forge ahead to be
whatever we wanted to be
for my sisters
that meant working globally and locally
to help children and communities thrive
for me
that meant being a public defender and
family lawyer
one night
when i was with a client at the
montgomery county jail and had to call
my mother to cancel our dinner date she
thought i was in jail
and almost had a heart attack
after i became a judge
she drove to rockville to quote watch me
in action
effective courts she said
were essential
to a strong democracy
mom's example meant much to me and my
sisters
she said that if we
or any other young women
wanted to compete successfully with men
we had to make sure our ideas were heard
and that meant
being willing
to interrupt
[Applause]
yes
interrupt
but when you do
make sure you have your thoughts in
order
and your facts straight
this is a lesson that mom imparted not
only to us
but to generations of students
at her beloved georgetown
during a teaching career that spanned
almost 40 years she never lost her
enthusiasm
often when i asked her what she'd be
doing over the weekend she responded
getting ready for monday's class
when i replied
don't you already know everything you
need to know
she said
there's always more to learn
mom was devoted to her students
and particularly looked forward to the
now famous role play
that showed students the realities of
decision-making
she taught through to the end of this
past year when her health was already
starting to fail
going to the hospital she took with her
a large binder of student papers i can
still see her propped up in bed
reading and grading
we often get asked
what kind of mother was she
she was the kind who usually called
every day
and sometimes twice
my time was 6 35 pm
how are the boys
how is work
when is your next trip
are you going running tonight
don't forget it's dark out
she was also the kind of mother that
took family celebrations very seriously
i would never miss a birthday a
graduation a wedding or an anniversary
and often called days in advance to
start planning
she surprised everyone at greg's and my
wedding which happened to be on
halloween by outfitting the entire
wedding party with elaborate feathered
masks
mom sparked an interest in all things
international
especially for me
we grew up devouring czech dumplings and
singing check christmas carols
when anne and i were 12 and katie was
six
she and dad took us on our first trip
across the atlantic to visit switzerland
and france
she loved speaking french one of the
five languages that she spoke fluently
and urged us to learn as well
for her this was a question of respect
and a lesson about understanding
perspectives
beyond our own
as i started to work in international
finance and development
mom was my best source of guidance
before my trips i often called her with
questions about the countries i was
about to visit
which u n conventions were relevant
what she knew about the political
environment
and of course
where i could pick up an extra pair of
red heels should i need them
she was always happy to give advice if i
asked
though sometimes it came with the
worried tone of a mother who knew too
much about the security situation and
some of the places where i was headed
mom had friends everywhere
and there's hardly a place where i have
landed where i have not been asked some
version of
is madeleine your mother
how is she
and then always followed by
we just love her
mom took a particular interest whenever
i let her know that i was visiting
refugees
or working to help girls get a better
chance for an education
often her voice would grow a bit deeper
the conversation slower
and i could tell that she was reminded
of being an 11 year old immigrant girl
who survived the blitz
moved around repeatedly
left her homeland
and arrived in the united states in 1948
with her sister brother and parents
seeking refuge and wanting a better
and safer future
even though she became one of the
world's top diplomats
mom never forget forgot where she came
from
and how precarious her circumstances
were when she first arrived in the
united states
this explained why mom never took
anything for granted
and was always grateful for everything
she described herself as a grateful
american
and took enormous pride in representing
the u.s abroad
now
when i look at my watch
i know that 6 35 pm
will never be the same for me and i will
be forever grateful mom for everything
you've given me
i miss you so much mom
and everything about you
and will forever
i'm the youngest
and tried my very best to take advantage
of that
by pushing the rules and boundaries
it didn't work
but mom also had rules for herself
as ann mentioned and president biden
she would always pick up the phone
when we called
but i still remember this one day she
didn't
i was in elementary school
and mom had recently started her
professional career
with her first job
on capitol hill
when i called her office
i was told
your mother can't come to the phone
right now because she's
on the floor
with senator muskie
i had no clue what that meant
as mom
tells the story
that night i ran up to her and i asked
what were you two doing on the floor
she then aptly explained to her young
daughter
how the legislative business of our
country
is conducted
on the senate floor
of course everyone in our family has a
favorite memory
and many of mom
permit me to share a few more
and i invite you to imagine them with us
picture mom
sitting on the sofa
with her feet up
glasses perched on her nose
knitting
knitting everything from little clothes
for our dolls to colorful cozy woolen
socks
think of her helping us to maneuver
a little red wagon
filled with girl scout cookies in the
spring
or campaign leaflets in the fall
along the crowded sidewalks and cobbled
streets of our neighborhood
with every step
an unspoken lesson in hard work
giving back
and civic participation
imagine mom
swooping down the colorado ski slopes
while wrapped in a purple parka and
fuzzy hat
or
more accurately snow plowing back and
forth
so cautiously that we teased her
of inventing a whole new sport
uphill skiing
but skiing
as in life
she always let us zoom ahead
and beamed at our daring
think of her at a commencement ceremony
indeed my own
from that very pulpit
decked out in her academic robes
urging young people to help one another
take risks laugh often and never leave
a friend behind
or in her dark blue suit
preparing for her historic confirmation
hearing
as america's
first
female
secretary of state
and what is she doing in the waiting
room
brushing our hair and giving us each a
tic tac
picture mom
cheeks of bright pink
as president obama
clasps medal of freedom around her neck
after which she shares with us the pride
she felt in her own parents
and the delight that her grandchildren
her grandes
could witness the day
envision her
leading our family
along the magical streets of prague
gleefully recounting the legends that
trolls and water pixies
and then guiding us through the
sorrowful exhibits of terezin
where more than two dozen of our
ancestors
were imprisoned
during the war
because of their jewish faith
none survived
with mom
the joys and the tears
were never entirely separated
imagine hands
that like hers were both soft
and strong
hands that exchange greetings with
numberless heads of state refugees
and fighters for freedom
hands that congratulated graduates and
new citizens
hands that tickled our toes when we were
young
took our temperatures when we were sick
held our babies
when newly born
and hands that often join together in
prayer
that people everywhere
might live in peace
finally
see in your mind's eye
a king james bible
dog-eared and worn
found by a window she loved
days after she passed
with a handwritten note
nearly
indecipherable
it read
micah 6 8
and the words
what does the lord
require of you
but to do justly
love mercy
and to walk humbly
with your god
i believe that this is truly how mom
tried to live every day of her life
and tried to teach us to do the same
dying was never on mom's schedule
a hole has opened in our hearts that we
lack the power to close
but the memory of her love
and the resilience of her example
will remain with us
and with many of you
until the end of our days
for that
mom
and for so much more
thank you
we love you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the lord be with you
let us pray
o god whose mercies cannot be numbered
accept our prayers on behalf of your
servant madeleine
and grant her an entrance into the land
of light and joy
in the fellowship of your saints
through jesus christ our lord who lives
and reigns with you and the holy spirit
one god now and forever
most merciful god whose wisdom is beyond
our understanding
deal graciously with madeleine's family
and friends and their grief
surround them with your love
that they may not be overwhelmed by
their loss
but have confidence in your goodness
and strength to meet the days to come
through jesus christ our lord
amen
please be seated
from what we might do together
by rabbi abraham joshua heschel
the survival of mankind is in the
balance
one wave of hatred
callousness or contempt
may bring in its wake the destruction of
all mankind
vicious deeds are but an aftermath of
what is conceived in the hearts and
minds of man
speech has power
and few men realize that words do not
fade
what set starts as a sound
ends in a deed
the world is too small for anything but
mutual care
and deep respect
the world is too great for anything but
responsibility
toward one another
from isaiah
chapter 61.
the spirit
of the lord god is upon me
elohim allah
allah
because
the lord has anointed me
god has sent me to bring good news to
the oppressed to bind up
the brokenhearted to proclaim liberty to
the captives
and released to the prisoners
to proclaim the year
of the lord's favor and the day of our
vengeance of our god to comfort all who
mourn
to provide for those who mourn in zion
to give them a garland instead of ashes
the oil of gladness
instead of mourning
the mantle of praise
instead of a
faint spirit
they
will be called oaks
of righteousness
the planting of the lord
to display god's glory
the word of the lord
we are all standing on madeline's step
i lift up my eyes to the hills
from where is my help to come
my help comes from the lord
the maker of heaven
and earth
the lord will not let your foot be moved
and the one who watches over you
will not fall asleep
behold the one who watches who keeps
watch
over israel
shall neither slumber
nor sleep
the lord
the lord watches over you
the lord
is your shade at your side
so that the sun shall not strike you by
day
nor the moon by night
the lord shall preserve you
from all evil
and shall keep you safe
the lord shall watch over your going
out and you're coming in
from this time forth
forevermore
you
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
righteousness
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
boy
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
a reading from the second letter of
saint paul to the corinthians
we do not lose heart
even though our outer nature is wasting
away
our inner nature is being renewed day by
day
for this slight momentary affliction
is preparing us for an eternal weight of
glory
beyond all measure
because we look not at what can be seen
but at what cannot be seen
but what can be seen is temporary
but what cannot be seen is eternal
or we know
that the
earthly tent we live in is destroyed
we have a building from god
a house not made with hands eternal in
the heavens
for in this tent we groan
longing to be clothed with our heavenly
dwelling
if indeed when we have taken it off
we will not be found naked
for while we are still in this tent
we grown under our burden
because we wish not to be unclothed but
to be further clothed
so that what is mortal may be swallowed
up by life
he who has prepared us for this this
very thing
is god
who has given us the spirit as a
guarantee
so we are always confident
even though we know that while we are at
home in the body
we are away from the lord
for we walk by faith
not by sight
yes we do have confidence
and we would rather be away from the
body and at home with the lord
so whether we are at home or away
we make it our aim to please him
the word of the lord
according to john
jesus told his disciples
do not let your hearts be troubled
believe in god
believe also in me
in my father's house there are many
dwelling places
if it were not so
would i have told you that i go to
prepare a place for you
and if i go and prepare a place for you
i will come again and will take you to
myself
so that where i am
there you may be also
and you know the way to the place where
i'm going
thomas said to him
lord
we do not know where you are going
how can we know the way
jesus said to him
i am the way
and the truth
and the life
no one comes to the father
except through me
the gospel of the lord
in the name of god amen
please be seated
let me begin by expressing my
condolences to the albright family
and to all who were blessed
to know madeleine albright as a
colleague mentor and friend
and thank you
for the honor of being part of this
celebration of her life it
it means more to me than i can say
the most important words have already
been spoken
and what we have heard about the one who
came into this world as
marie janna corbell or madlinka as she
was known as a child
is a testimony to the theological adage
the glory of god is a human being
fully
alive
drawing upon every circumstance and
experience both wondrous
and harsh
madeleine learned to live fully and well
as the apostle paul wrote of his own
life
when she had little
and when she had plenty
in times of hardship and in times
of joy
i can do all things through him who
strengthens me
paul wrote
madeleine in her writing is more
circumscri
circumspect about her faith in god
though it rans like an undercurrent
beneath every word
i've spent the last two weeks
reading her memoirs and some of her
speeches which has felt
a bit like a master class in life
and leadership
i should have learned i
i'm expecting especially given all that
we've heard today
about her capacity for self-reflection
awareness not only her strengths of her
vulnerabilities
her ability to celebrate accomplishments
but also
to acknowledge the mistakes
lives are
necessarily untidy and uneven she wrote
it is important however
to have
some guiding star
for me she said that star has always
been
faith in the democratic process that
each person
should be able to go as far as her or
his talents
will allow
i've also learned about many of you
as seen through madeleine's eyes
she was effusive in her praise
and admiration
quick to celebrate your gifts and
contributions
to her family to the country
and beyond she was generous and
respectful to those with whom she
disagreed sometimes vehemently
on matters of policy
she was discreet
and she had the capacity to
recognize as brian stephen so stevenson
so powerfully reminds us that each one
of us
is more than the worst thing we have
ever done
or
the best thing for that matter
ourselves in public
or how we are perceived by others
we are more
given role in another person's life more
than our opinions on a certain
issue
and certainly more than our affiliation
in political party
faith tradition nationality
or whatever else might serve to separate
us from one another
and she clearly honored
that
complexity
and breadth
in everyone
never once in her writings did she
describe herself as a godly person
but as i read i kept thinking about
words from the benedictine non-joan
twister
who writes
the godly are those who
never talk destructively about another
person
in anger in spite
in vengefulness
and can and hear this and can be counted
on
to bring an open heart
to a closed and clawing world
she goes on
the holy ones are those who live well
with those around them
just they're upright
they are kind
the ecology of humankind
is safe
with
the them of humankind
was safe
with madeleine albright
she had strong words for those who in
her estimation abused their power
and caused others to suffer
most especially for those on the world
stage whose actions adversely affected
millions
and she did all in her power
to defeat them
speaking of power
madeleine wrote that her political
career began when she served on the
board of trustees at beauvoir school
the early elementary school here on the
cathedral close
in life one thing leads to another and
in washington one personal
recommendation does too
she writes of her time on the
cathedral's leadership board known as
the chapter during a time when this nave
was being expanded
and at the service
when the this expanded knaves quarter
stone was being laid she apparently read
a lesson from this pulpit
tasting a [ __ ] she said of her
childhood dream of becoming a priest
though the episcopal church had yet to
ordain women
and she claimed that she learned
as much about politics on the cathedral
chapter as she did working in campaigns
which you know is true
but i dare say she also learned as much
about faith in the political arena as
she did in church
because that is where her faith
was lived
i'd like to dwell a bit longer on
madeleine's understanding of power
by way of illustration though let me
share a moment seared in my memory
that some of you may also recall
it was on the day of president obama's
second inauguration
and we had gathered at st john's
church lafayette square
for a private prayer service for the
president vice president and your
families
and other
sundry invited guests i i don't know if
madeline was there
the preacher that day was andy stanley
from north point church in atlanta
and he stood at the pulpit and he looked
at the president and
then he looked at
all of us
and he asked
what do you do
when you know
that you're the most powerful person
in the room
we've all been that person he said
parent president
and the question is
what do we do when we know
what do we do
with that power
good preacher that he was stanley
reminded us of the night jesus of
nazareth shared a final meal meal with
his disciples before his arrest and
execution
clearly he was the most powerful person
in that room
and he assumed the role of a servant
washing his disciples
feet
for madeleine albright power was an
essential tool
for making things happen
she felt called to positions of
authority and influence and actively
pursued those positions unapologetically
and astutely the chapter in which she
describes
lobbying behind the scenes to be
president clinton's choice for secretary
of state ought to be required reading
for every woman aspiring to leadership
anywhere sheer brilliance
she relished being the most powerful
person in the room
and she used her power in service to
others and to empower
others we've heard that over and over
again today
when she needed to take on the world's
biggest bully she did
unflinchingly on the exterior
no matter how she felt
on the inside
and when she needed to hold back or to
pivot or to compromise she did that too
mastering the art of what our presiding
bishop describes as
standing and kneeling at the same time
which is to say being strong in
conviction
and humble in spirit
and she was also aware
as we all are
that with increasing positions of power
mistakes become more costly
and her mistakes grieved her
as did her failures
but she was determined
to learn from them
and carry on
i'd like to close with a nod
toward the mystery of the eternal
consequences of our lives
acknowledging the ancient human
intuition embedded in all faith
traditions
that there is in fact
another realm
beyond this life
and i'm still on this side of death
myself like all of you so i know as much
about it as you do
but i believe in it
because of what connects us in this life
to that other realm
those moments when we feel the power of
transcendence and grace
of peace surpassing understanding
of unconditional love
and of faith
as the assurance of things hoped for and
the conviction of things
unseen
and the best way
to prepare for that other realm is to
live fully
in this one
to cherish life until the time comes for
us to let it go
and to do what we can to make life
better for others so let me leave you
with madeline's closing words from
prague winter
her exploration of her jewish heritage
and the cataclysmic events that shaped
her early childhood
as you can imagine she cited many
examples of cruelty and betrayal in that
heartbreaking book
but she writes they are not what i will
take with me
as i move to life's next chapter
in the world where i choose to live
even the coldest winter must yield to
ancient agents of spring
and the darkest view of human nature
eventually find room
for shafts of light
and she concludes with this
i've spent a lifetime
looking for remedies
for all manner of life's problems
personal social political global
i believe
that we can recognize truth when we see
it
just not at first
and not ever
and with and not without ever relenting
in our effort
to know
more
this is because
the goal we seek and the good we hope
for
comes
not as a final reward
but as the hidden companion in our quest
it's not what we find
but the reason we cannot stop looking
and striving
that tells us
why we are here
you don't need me to remind you that we
live in perilous times
and i have no doubt
that madeleine's final words to us
would be ones of encouragement to keep
looking for the truth striving for good
and cherishing life in all its wondrous
complexity
and beauty
to claim our power
and to use it for good she would want us
all to follow our north star
what ultimate purpose
guides us in times of grace and
adversity
and calls us back
whenever we stray off course
so leave here today
in the words of charles wesley to do all
the good you can
by all the means you can
in all the places you can
at all the times you can for all the
people you can
for as long
as you can
and as you do the god of compassion
we'll go with you
and rest assured that madeleine
is cheering you on
amen
so
oh
[Music]
[Music]
me
is
[Music]
i
see
twas
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you
please stand as you are able and in the
assurance of eternal life given at
baptism
let us proclaim our faith and say
i believe in god
the
almighty
creator of heaven and earth
i believe in jesus christ his only son
our lord
he was conceived by the power of the
holy spirit
and born of the virgin mary
he suffered under pontius pilate
was crucified died and was buried
he descended to the dead
on the third day he rose again
and ascended into heaven
and is seated at the right hand of the
father
he will come again to judge the living
and the dead
i believe in the holy spirit
the holy catholic church
the communion of saints
the forgiveness of sins
the resurrection of the body
and the life everlasting
let us pray together in the words our
savior christ taught us
our father who art in heaven
hallowed be thy name
thy kingdom come
thy will be done
on earth as it is in heaven
give us this day our daily bread
and forgive us our trespasses
as we forgive those who trespass against
us
and lead us not into temptation
but deliver us from evil
for thine is the kingdom and the power
and the glory
forever and ever
amen
for our sister madeleine
let us pray to our lord jesus christ who
said
i am resurrection
and i am life
lord
you consoled martha and mary in their
distress
draw near to us who mourn for madeleine
and dry the tears of those who weep
hear us
you wept at the grave of lazarus your
friend
comfort us
in our sorrow
you raise the dead to life
give to our sister eternal life
you promised paradise to the thief who
repented
bring our sister
to the joys of heaven
our sister was washed in baptism and
anointed with the holy spirit
give her fellowship with all your saints
she was nourished with your body and
blood
grant her a place at the table
in your heavenly kingdom
comfort us in our sorrows
at the death of our sister
let our faith be our consolation
and eternal life our hope
father of all we pray to you for
madeline and for all those whom we love
but see no longer
grant to them eternal rest let light
perpetual shine upon them
may her soul and the souls of all the
departed
through the mercy of god
rest in peace
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
my
[Music]
good
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
give rest o christ
to your servant with your saints
the sorrow and pain are no more
other side but life everlasting
you only are immortal the creator and
maker of mankind and we are mortal
formed of the earth and to the earth
shall we return
for so did you ordain when you created
me saying
you are dust and to dust you shall
return
all of us go down to the dust yet even
at the grave we make our song alleluia
alleluia
give rest alleluia christ to your
servant with your sins
into your hands o merciful savior we
commend your servant madeleine
acknowledge we humbly beseech you
a sheep of your own fold a lamb of your
own flock
a sinner of your own redeeming
receive her
into the arms of your mercy
into the blessed rest of everlasting
peace
and into the glorious company of the
saints
in light
amen
now may the lord
bless you
and keep you
the lord make his face to shine upon you
and be gracious to you
the lord lift up his countenance upon
you
and give you peace
amen
let us go forth in the name of christ
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
more
[Music]
now
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you
you guys to be a favorite
employee morale
and gross mismanagement left the
department in bad shape and the american
people less secure
the biden administration has prioritized
rebuilding dhs
and supporting its more than 250 000
hard-working men and women
under secretary marcus leadership dhs
has fulfilled critical vacancies
strengthened management and advocated
for pay raises and collective bargaining
rights for frontline workers
meanwhile dhs has faced unprecedented
challenges from a rise in domestic
terrorism to escalating cyber threats
from russia
to more frequent and severe
you